[موسيقى]
هذا الصيف شاهدنا ارتفاعا تاريخيا في
حراره الارض متوسط الحراره العالمي بلغ
17.23 درجه مئويه وهو الاعلى منذ 125 الف
سنه وفق العلماء
[موسيقى]
والسبب التغير المناخي المتسارع نحو
الاسوا فماذا ينتظر كوكبنا نتيجتها هذه
الظاهره
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده حددت خمسه مسارات للمستقبل
الاكثر تفاؤلا
سيناريو رسمته اتفاقيه باريس للمناخ
بابقاء ارتفاع درجه الحراره عند 1.5 يتخلص
العالم من فائض ثاني اكسيد الكربون
تدريجيا لتصل نسبته الى الصفر الصافي في
عام 2050 وتتحول المجتمعات الى ممارسات
اكثر استدامه ويتفادى العالم اسوا تداعيات
التغير المناخي
[موسيقى]
التحسن البطيء
تنخفض انبعاثات غاز ثاني اكسيد الكربون
بشده لكن بسرعه اقل لتصل الى الصفر الصافي
بعد 2050
هذا السيناريو قائم على تحولات اجتماعيه
واقتصاديه لتحقيق الاستدامه الوارده في
السيناريو الاول على ان يستقر ارتفاع درجه
الحراره عند 1.8 درجات مئويه بنهايه القرن
منتصف الطريق
تتارجح بعثات ثاني اكسيد الكربون حول
مستوياتها الحاليه وتبدا في التراجع في
منتصف القرن وصولا الى الصفر بحلول عام
2100 ثم ترتفع درجات الحراره
2.7 درجات مئويه
توازن مهدد
في هذا المسار ترتفع الانبعاثات ودرجات
الحراره باضطراد وتزيد انبعاثات ثاني
اكسيد الكربون ضعفي المستويات الحاليه عام
2100 وتركز الدول طاقتها على ضمان
الامدادات الغذائيه لشعوبها وترتفع درجات
الحراره
3.6 درجات مئويه في نهايه القرن
المسار الاسوا يتضاعف انبعاث ثاني اكسيد
الكربون مرتين بحلول الفين وخمسين ويزيد
استغلال الوقود الاحفوري واستهلاك الطاقه
تزامنا مع نمو الاقتصاد العالمي بوتيره
سريعه وترتفع درجات الحراره العالميه
اربعا اربع درجات مئويه قبل عام 2100
العلماء يجمعون على ظواهر سترافق كل
السيناريوهات منها استمرار ارتفاع درجات
الحراره بضعه عقود على الاقل وارتفاع
مستوى مياه البحار لمئات السنوات واختفاء
الثلوج البحريه في القطب الشمالي في احد
فصول الصيف خلال العقود الثلاثه المقبله
لكن مدى خطوره هذه الظواهر يتعلق بالمسار
الذي يختاره العالم